[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de la semaine au
Parlement et cette semaine nous accuons
Naima mchou bonjour Merci d'être sur le
plateau de Parlement Hebdo vous êtes
député horizon du valdoise et
vice-présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
et cette semaine on parlera avec vous du
projet de loi immigration qui va être
débattu à partir de ce lundi au Sénat
sujet de discorde Gérald daranin n'a
toujours pas trouvé d'accord sur ce
texte avec la majorité de droite
sénatoriale le droit à l'avortement
bientôt inscrit dans la Constitution le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé un projet de loi
constitutionnel pour protéger la liberté
des femmes à recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et puis
Elizabeth borne continue de dégainer les
articles 493 pour faire adopter le
budget de la Sécurité sociale faute de
majorité sur ce texte les sénateurs vont
donc débuter ce lundi l'examen du projet
de loi immigration l'article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension
pourrait faire échouer l'adoption de ce
texte au Sénat Adrien pin l'hypothèse
d'un accord entre droite sénatorial et
gouvernement semble être au point mort
au cœur des dissensions l'article 3 qui
prévoit la régularisation des
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en tenstion une partie de la droite
demande sa suppression et le président
du groupe LR au Sénat refuse tout
compromis ce que je veux c'est que le de
travailler ne donne pas droit à
régularisation parce que vous pouvez
avoir d'ailleurs des
islamistes qui travaillent moi ce que je
veux c'est que le préfet puisse par la
voie réglementaire se dire ok il
travaille ça se passe bien mais en même
temps il est ou elle intégrable pour
mettre la pression sur le gouvernement
les républicains ont lancé une pétition
sur l'immigration mais pas question de
lâcher du l'est sur l'article 3 pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui trouve déjà
le projet de loi assz ferme pourquoi on
tient cet article parce qu'il doit avoir
une différence non pas entre l'étranger
et le National mais entre l'étranger qui
veut s'intégrer et qui respecte nos
règles et celui qui ne respect pas nos
règles sans les voix de leurs alliés
centristes les sénateurs et n'auront pas
de majorité pour supprimer l'article 3
or les centristes acceptent seulement de
le modifier il craignent que le texte ne
puisse pas être voté s'il est trop durci
ça devient n'importe quoi l'article 3
les travailleurs en tension c'est un
périmètre très restreint comme on a
obtenu beaucoup de choses problème c'est
de savoir si on veut ou si on veut pas
que ce texte soit voté en commission les
sénateurs ont notamment restreint les
conditions de regroupement familial ils
envisagent aussi de transformer l'aide
médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence avec un panier de soins
restreint d'autres amendements prévoient
de supprimer toute protection contre
mesure d'expulsion du territoire
français la chambre haute examine le
projet de loi jusqu'au 10 novembre
naimamutchu on le voit la mesure qui
divise dans dans ce projet de loi
immigration c'est l'article 3 de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension une
mesure qui ne fait pas l'unanimité au
sein de la majorité présidentielle Vous
avez déclaré récemment que cet article 3
encourageait l'immigration clandestine
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous allez
proposer un amendement de suppression de
cet article quand le texte immigration
va arriver à l'Assemblée alors c'est
vrai j'ai dit et je le redis pour moi
l'article 3 effectivement doit faire
partie de ces sujets qui doivent être
débattus à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
quelque chose d'important je pense qu'il
faut d'abord réaffirmer que notre
objectif c'est de lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière et donc j'ai
un problème intellectu à l'idée de dire
que se maintenir sur le territoire de
manière illégale ouvrirait des
droits donc c'est une problématique et
c'est une problématique qui est plutôt
partagée j'ai l'impression y compris
avec auprès de mes collègues sénateurs
en tout cas un certain nombre de
collègues sénateurs c'est d'autant plus
vrai que la rédaction actuelle de
l'article 3 elle indique que plus vous
vous maintenez illégalement sur le
territoire plus vous avez des chances
d'être régularisé et notre priorité ça
doit être au contraire la lutte contre
le trafic de main d'œuvre contre les
patrons voyou alors ils le sont pas tous
mais enfin il y en a certains parce que
le travail illégal c'est quand même une
une économie d'exploitation euh qui a
des conséquences très graves en matière
de tension sociale en matière évidemment
d'économie souterraine mais et en même
temps je vais vous dire je vois le pays
réel je je vois ce qui se passe dans la
société il y a des travailleurs
irréguliers dans ce pays et donc il faut
se poser la question de ce qui se passe
de ce qu'on peut faire les éloigner
alors qu'ils serait intégrés ça n'est
pas non plus une solution et donc je dis
la régularisation automatique et de
plein droit telle qu'elle est écrite
c'est un problème regarder au cas par
cas ce serait davantage effectivement
faire preuve de justice donc pour vous
faut supprimer cet article 3 et passer
par une circulaire quel est qu'est-ce
que vous allez proposer vous ma position
d'abord ma position je veux le redire
encore une fois c'est c'est de cet
article 3 ça ne peut pas être un chiffon
rouge ou un totem de ma part donc vous
êtes prêt à voter le texte même si les
conservé tel qu'elle mais je veux faire
mon travail de parlementaire je veux
faire mon travail de parlementaire et
faire des propositions pour une
rédaction éventuelle nouvelle de cet
article 3 et d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur a tendu la main sur ce sujet
en disant que les parlementaires
pouvaient proposer pouvit être amendé
effectivement et améliorer ce texte je
crois que la régularisation au cas par
cas est la solution qui doit être
envisagée aujourd'hui et cela existe
déjà avec une circulaire la circulaire
Vals vous souhaitez quoi précisément
comme amélioration mais justement il
faut voir si nous avons la capacité
aujourd'hui de transposer dans la loi
cette régularisation au cas par cas
c'est une vraie question parce que en
tant que législateur nous pouvons au cas
d'espèce réécrire finalement quelque
part dans la loi cette cette circulaire
et si cet article 3 n'est pas amélioré
dans sa rédaction comme vous le proposez
est-ce que vous voterez quand même ce
projet de loi immigration je vais vous
dire ce texte il est indispensable voilà
il n'est pas suffisant parce que le défi
migratoire il est immense hein ce qui
arrive devant nous peut pas être réglé à
lui seul par un seul texte il est
insuffisant je le dis mais il est
insuffisant parce que quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe les mouvement
de population dans le monde les guerres
la misère le le la corruption mais aussi
le réchauffement climatique il va y
avoir des mouvements de population vers
l'Europe des mouvements importants donc
un seul texte de loi à lui seul ne peut
pas répondre au défis migratoire mais ce
texte il est nécessaire il est
indispensable parce qu'il apporte des
réponses c'est un texte ambiux c'est
votre position ou c'est celle aussi qui
est partagée par d'autres membres de
votre groupe horizon est-ce que tout le
groupe Horizon est critique sur cet
article 3 alors c débats ce sont des
débats que nous allons avoir mais au
sein du groupe au raison vous savez on a
plutôt une expression libre voilà loyale
maises libre votre oui c'est la mienne
que j'ai exprimé j'en ai discuté avec un
certain nombre de mes collègues je crois
qu'on se retrouve autour de cette idée
se retrouve en tout cas autour de la
nécessité de parler de cet article 3
mais évidemment nous considérons
ensemble que c'est un texte ambitieux
parce qu'il propose de raccourcir les
délais de simplifier les procédures de
mieux lutter contre ceux qui troublent
l'ordre public et ça évidemment c'est
une nécessité un collectif de
parlementaires qui rassemble des députés
modemes jusqu'au communistes va proposer
une série d'amendements communs sur ce
texte notamment pour conserver cette
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier est-ce que ça veut dire que la
majorité peut se fracturer sur ce texte
votre majorité en tout cas ce qui est
sain c'est que nous ayons des vrais
débats de fond moi c'est ce que
j'appelle de mes vœux c'est que nous
puissions débattre sur ce texte et que
nous ne fassions pas ce qui arrive
traditionnellement quand on parle
d'immigration c'est-à-dire qu'on
s'enferme dans des postures et dans des
slogans donc si un travail de réécriture
y compris effectivement de l' plutôt
gauche de la majorité ou de groupe de
laanupass c'est intéressant et puis nous
confronterons les opinions et puis nous
irons au vote donc j'appelle de mes vœux
cet exercice qui est l'exercice par
essence du Parlement mais je demande
effectivement que nous sortions d'un
certain nombre de clichés et de
caricature sur le sujet sur le fond quel
autre durcissement du projet de loi
immigration vous souhaitez par exemple
est-ce que vous souhaitez durcir l'aide
médicale d'État pour la transformer en
aide médicale d'urgence comme le
proposent les sénateurs les républicains
alors je ne sais pas s'il s'agit de
durcir moi je préfère parler
d'amélioration d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs et d'outils évidemment qu'il
y a la question de l'aide médicale
d'État de tout façon vous le savez ce
sujet il est récurrent il est permanent
il revient intervalle régulier et et je
vais vous dire c'est sain de
s'interroger interval régulier sur ces
sujets il y a la question du panier de
soins je le dis très clairement il ne
s'agit pas de supprimer l'accès au soins
au travailleurs en situation
irrégulière d'abord pour des questions
d'humanisme de manière très triviale et
très simple et puis par ailleurs il y a
des questions de santé publique qui se
posent en revanche en revanche notre
responsabilité c'est de regarder de plus
près de voir si le système peut-être
amélioré en restreignant l'accès aux
soins à des soins indispensables sur
l'immigration est-ce que vous assumez
tout de même d'être plus proche d'un
député LR que d'un député Renaissance
puisque vous souhaitez durcir certaines
mesures je vais vous dire j'assume de
dire ce que j'ai envie de dire ce que je
crois ce que je crois être le meilleur
pour l'intérêt général je me positionne
pas par rapport à tel ou tel euh je dis
je dis simplement que il faut regarder
ce qui se passe il faut regarder le pays
réel nous le devons aux Français vous
savez combien de compatriotes sont
inquiets sur les sujets d'immigration et
donc il faut être en capacité de faire
les constats qui s'imposent de dépasser
les nonis sur le sujet et encore une
fois de proposer ce qui nous paraît être
le plus adéquat on l'a entendu he vous
défendez vous défendez l'essentiel de ce
texte pour l'instant le gouvernement n'a
pas de majorité sur ce projet de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale si ça reste le cas
est-ce qu'il faudra passer par un 4 3
est-ce que c'est nécessaire pour faire
adopter ce texte que vous défendez je ne
sais pas si c'est le scénario
aujourd'hui qui est envisagé je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tous les scénarios sont
sur la table les sénateurs vont bientôt
examiner en séance publique ce texte
c'est la première étape et ensuite c'est
à l'Assemblée nationale de de participer
au débat nous verrons ce qui en
ressortira je pense que c'est un peu
prématuré je crois qu'il faut se donner
toutes les chances d'aller au bout et
d'aller au vote y compris s'il s'agit de
mettre devant leur responsabilité chacun
des groupes d'opposition encore une fois
c'est un débat trop important pour qu'il
soit esquamoté en tout cas les LR
menacent de leur côté de déposer une
motion de censure ce serait une première
pour ce groupe de dans le cas quia les
oppositions auraient alors les moyens de
faire tomber le gouvernement est-ce que
vous croyez ce scénario possible alors
tout est possible évidemment tout est
possible on le dit depuis un an puisque
ce ne serait pas la première motion de
censure il y en a eu quelquesunes déjà
et encoreou et encore il y a quelques
jours oui alors elle pourrait aboutir
par par que la nouveauté ce serait ici
que les républicains seraient à la
manœuvre mais j'ai entendu le groupe
socialiste notamment indiquer qu'il ne
voteraient pas la motion en question
donc pour vous il y aura pas de de
motion de censure qui sera adoptée dans
ce quinquena si finalement les
oppositions ne sont pas Unies non moi
j'ai pas de boule de cristal je ne peux
pas vous dire je vois que les
oppositions en tout cas ne sont pas en
capacité aujourd'hui effectivement de
former une majorité alternative
naimamutchou on va poursuivre cette
émission avec cette liberté des femmes à
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse qui serait gravé dans la
Constitution pour la rendre irréversible
en 2024 c'est en tout cas l'annonce
cette semaine d'Emmanuel Macron le texte
est désormais entre les mains du Conseil
d'État en vue d'une présentation en
conseil des ministres d'ici la fin de
l'année Elsa
mondangava c'est sur le réseau social x
anciennement Twitter que le Président de
la République a confirmé en 2024 la
liberté des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
sera irréversible le gouvernement est en
train de posé un projet de loi
constitutionnel pour inscrire à
l'article 34 la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme qui lui est garantie
d'avoir recours à une interruption
volontaire de grossesse si ce droit est
aujourd'hui défendu sur la quasi-ttalité
des bans de cet hémicycle nous avons un
devoir de vigilance vous l'avez rappelé
la décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis l'année dernière a rappelé
que le droit à l'avortement veut être
menacé même dans une grande démocratie
et jusque sur notre continent plusieurs
partis d'extrême droite veulent remettre
en cause cette liberté fondamentale pour
les femmes les insoumis qui avaient fait
adopter en novembre dernier une
proposition de loi pour
constitutionnaliser l'IVG se disprêt à
voter le texte et en accepter la
rédaction même si eux préfère le mot
droit à celui de liberté je suis attaché
au fait que on réindique que le droit à
l'avortement est un droit fondamental
humain mais moi je vais vous dire ce
n'est pas ma formulation celle du Sénat
mais évidemment je la voterai la droite
elle est moins convaincu par
l'initiative le président de la
République a un drôle de sens de des
priorités du et du tempo n propose une
réforme de la Constitution sur sur sur
l'IVG qui n'a voilà qui me semble pas
être la priorité du moment personne en
France n'a remis en cause l'interruption
volontaire de de grossesse au Parlement
un projet de loi ouvre la voie à une
adoption l'année prochaine par le
Congrès la réunion des députés et
sénateurs alors Naim mu il y a une
bataille sémantique un peu le choix des
mots est important dans tel que la
rédaction s Présidente il y aurait le
mot liberté des femmes à recourir à
l'IVG plutôt que droit des femmes est-ce
que cette rédaction vous combient est-ce
que vous souhaitez que le mot droit des
femmes à l'IVG figure dans le futur
texte c'est c'est un débat que nous
aurons prochainement puisque
vraisemblablement le président de la
République a indiqué que cette
proposition ce projet de loi
constitutionnel serait examiné en
2024 je je je je ne sais pas en tant que
tel si c'est une avancée parce que je
considère que en tout cas je constate
que les responsables politiques en
France en tout cas aujourd'hui ne
remettent pas en cause le droit mais il
faut quand même inscrire l'IVG dans la
Constitution mais mais c'est un symbole
c'est éminemment symbolique éminemment
symbolique pour les femmes et c'est vrai
que dans un contexte de tension dans un
contexte effectivement où le lien social
en particulier est remise en cause et
même si je n'aime pas importer les
débats outreAtlantique tout de même
c'est vrai que ce serait un symbole ce
serait un symbole puissant de l'inscrire
demain dans la Constitution alors on va
revenir sur l'utilité de cette révision
constitutionnelle mais peut-être une
réaction quand même sur le mot est-ce
que vous préférez qu'on mette droit à
l'IVG dans la constitution ou liberté
des femmes à recourir à l'vg
effectivement ça ça ça ne dit pas la
même chose un droit est opposable devant
un juge alors ça n'est pas ce que je
préfère ou ce que je ne préfère pas
encore une fois moi je je veux laisser
la place au débat je je n'ai pas
d'opinion qui est faite aujourd'hui pour
pourquoi parce que d'abord je je
considère que on ne modifie pas la
constitution d'un coup de crayon le fait
la main tremblante et donc ce sont des
débats très sérieux il faut savoir ce
qu'emporte comme conséquence chacun de
ces termes la capacité ou pas pour le
législateur d'intervenir en fait c'est
ça la question la question c'est celle
de la sécurité la sécurité de l'IVG
est-ce qu'un terme emporte plus de
sécurité ou pas que l'autre puisque le
problème en tout cas le le la raison
pour laquelle on vaut inscrireivg dans
la Constitution c'est bien pour qu'il ne
soit plus jamais remise en cause et il
l' en France aujourd'hui pour vous c'est
ce que je vous dis j'ai il ne l'est pas
pour moi il ne l'est pas en tout cas moi
je n'ai pas entendu de responsable
politique venir remettre en cause ce
droit à l'IVG et bien heureusement bien
heureusement mais encore une fois quand
on fait de la politique quand on fait la
loi on n'est pas que sur des mesures
techniques on le sait il y a aussi des
symboles très forts qui doivent être
inscrit pourquoi pas dans la
Constitution donc pour vous c'est une
portée symbolique finalement quand des
parlementaires comme Marine Pen comme
Bruno rotillo le président du groupe LR
au Sénat disent que cette révision
constitutionnelle est inutile car comme
vous l'avez dit et bien le droit à
l'avortement est déjà protégé par la loi
veille en France c'est juste voilà on
est simplement dans dans le symbole avec
ce texte non parce que le symbole il est
jamais inutile jamais
sinon tous ces principes qui seraient
inscrits dans la Constitution alors il
serait inutile non c'est pas comme ça
que je réfléchis encore une fois c'est
un sujet important c'est un sujet de
société qui est important et parfois
effectivement l'inscrire dans le marbre
et bien c'est un message un message
puissant qu'on envoie à la population en
tout cas pour que qu'il soit adopté ce
texte doit l'être dans les mêmes termes
par les deux Chambres c'est un processus
long est-ce que vous craignez que
finalement la majorité sénatoriale de
droite ne fasse échouer cette
inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution aurait-elle intérêt à le
faire je ne sais pas à moins que les les
sénateurs soient divisés sur cette
question mais nous verrons nous verrons
ça leur appartient et en cas d'échec de
cette réforme constitutionnelle au
Parlement est-ce qu'il faudrait passer
directement par référendum devant les
Français alors ça c'est une possibilité
mais elle appartient au président de la
République aujourd'hui vous avez pas de
position sur sur ce point peut-être un
mot sur quand même le calendrier de
cette annonce est-ce que c'est le bon
tempo est-ce que c'est la priorité du
moment pour reprendre les mots d'Olivier
marlex alors que on parle beaucoup de
d'immigration de sécurité et une
inquiétude des Français sur ce sujet
est-ce que c'est pas une diversion
d'Emmanuel Macron d'annoncer ça
maintenant non je ne crois pas vous
savez moi je je ne rentre pas dans ces
considérants qui sont des des des enfin
qui sont pour moi en tout cas à mes yeux
de niveau niveau de débat de politique
politicien on dit souvent ça n'est pas
le moment pour tel ou tel alors ça n'est
jamais le moment pour rien le contexte
aujourd'hui difficile vous avez raison
et en particulier le contexte social ou
la pression terroriste nous ne sommes
pas à côté de ces sujets là il y a un
texte sur l'immigration qui sera porté
par le ministre de l'Intérieur un texte
ambition et nous le soutenons sur le
contexte social il y a un projet de loi
de finance avec un certain nombre de
mesures qui viennent en soutien du
pouvoir d'achat en soutien des plus
modestes des plus précaires des
étudiants donc il y a des choses qui
sont faites à côté de ça il y a
effectivement d'autres thématiques et
s'il y a la place de mener les débats
alors il faut le faire est-ce que vous
craignez un retour de la mobilisation
des des mouvements prove prove qu'on
avait pu voir récemment sur pour
empêcher cette inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution
c'est un risque oui parce que ce sont
des des débats toujours très abrasif
pour la société voilà ce sont des sujets
qui qui qui réveillent les clivages
sociétaux et donc tout comme pour la fin
de vie puisque c'est aussi un sujet qui
pourrait venir en débat à l'Assemblée
nationale plus de précision sur le
calend jeen ai pas davantage non j'ai
pas plus d'information texte sur la fin
de vie non absolument pas mais
effectivement c'est un risque et donc du
du justement avec ces débats sociétaux
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas que la
cohésion sociale en France ne soit
encore un peu plus abîmée par le fait de
mettre ces débats sur la table nous
devrons être vigilants ça c'est vrai
devrons être vigilants nous devrons
faire œuvre de pédagogie il faudra
prendre les moyens d'expliquer ce qui
est fait et pourquoi c'est fait et et et
et notamment sur le sujet de la fin de
vie qui est inflammable vous souhaitez
qu'il y ait un débat sur que ce texte
soit inscrit à l'ordre du jour à
l'Assemblée sur la fin de vie votre
souhait personnel alors c'est c'est un
sujet important c'est un sujet très
important c'est vrai
euh je ne suis pas favorable à ce qu'il
vienne immédiatement je ne crois pas que
le sujet soit suffisamment mû
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'étapes à franchir
d'abord avant d'évoquer ce sujet y
compris dans le débat public par le
Parlement alors naouiamchou dans la nuit
de lundi à mardi à l'Assemblée nationale
ellisabeth borne a déclenché une fois de
plus l'article 493 de la Constitution
pour faire passer cette fois sans vote
le texte du budget 2024 de la sécurité
sociale c'est la 15e fois que la chef du
gouvernement a recours à cette arme on
l'écoute pour ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale comme
pour tous les textes depuis un an et
demi les ministres ont mené des
concertations et nous avons tendu la
main aux
oppositions cependant malgré notre
volonté de dialogue aucun groupe
d'opposition souité dévier sur de sa
ligne nous devons protéger notre modèle
social nous devons améliorer le
quotidien de nos concitoyen aussi sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur la 3è partie et
l'ensemble du projet de loit de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie alors les motion de censure
succède au 493 à l'Assemblée courtant
les les discussions est-ce que le débat
budgétaire a encore un sens dans ces
conditions vous qui présidez souvent les
ces débats
budgétaires je vais vous dire très très
franchement ce que j'en pense les le
déclenchement du 493 ça n'est jamais
quelque chose de de très agréable ni
même de satisfaisant pour un
parlementaire le cœur de métier du
député ou du sénateur d'ailleurs c'est
le débat c'est la possibilité qu'on a de
proposer de de confronter les opinions
et puis d'aller au vote pour exprimer
une position politique et donc moi je
suis attaché à cette essence qui'est le
débat pour le Parlement mais évidemment
le gouvernement n'a pas le choix le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix
aujourd'hui c'est même une question de
responsabilité pour l'exécutif parce que
sinon quoi un pays sans budget un pays
sans sans loi de finances les
oppositions ont dit exactement comme
l'an dernier qu'ell refusaient de voter
le budget c'est un refus catégorique
dans ces conditions il fallait
déclencher le 493 et et ce que je
constate avec un peu d'amusement c'est
que ce ceux qui se plaignent aujourd'hui
de l'utilisation du 493 voire qui en
demande la suppression à gauche comme à
droite sont les mêmes quand ils étaient
aux responsabilités qui ont utilisé ce
493 sera y compris sur des textes
d'ailleurs très contestés la loi CPE
sous le gouvernement vilpin la loi
camerce le gouvernement Vals voilà donc
il y a nécessité il y a nécessité il
faut se rappeler encore une fois
simplement pour en terminer il faut se
rappeler l'esprit des fondateurs de la
Constitution et de Debray de cet article
49 alinéa 3 sous l'autorité de c'est un
outil c'est un moyen de débloquer les
situations alors selon vous le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix du 493
mais en tout cas le gouvernement a le
choix de laisser le débat parlementaire
aller à son terme sur ce budget de la
Sécurité sociale et de voir quels
amendements il pourrait retenir au final
avec le 493 il y a même plus cette
volonté là de de laisser le débat dans
l'hémicycle se faire de la part du
gouvernement oui alors là aussi je
constate que l'an dernier quand on a
laissé le débat se faire les oppositions
s'en sont plein estimant que les débats
étaient galvodé que c'était un simulacre
de débat et que quand le gouvernement
décide d'aller effectivement un peu plus
vite les oppositions ne sont toujours
pas satisfaites donc donc je m'interroge
mais d'abord les débats ont lieu en
commission c'est important de le dire
dans chaque commission je suis sur
chacune des thématique du projet de loi
de finances ensuite il y a une question
là encore de
responsabilité si si nous démarrons les
débats et que pleuent les amendements et
les milliards pour les dépenses
publiques c'est une problématique c'est
une problématique ensuite pour le
déclenchement du 493 et pour faire le
choix de tel ou tel amendement final
donc donc la responsabilité ici
l'emporte oui vous dites il y a eu un
débat en commission des finances c'est
vrai et notamment sur un sujet très
sensible la question de taxer les super
dividendes il y avait une partie de la
majorité qui souhaitait qu'il ait une
taxe finalement elle n'aura pas lieu
est-ce que vous le regrettez moi je
trouve en tout cas le débat intéressant
très intéressant euh je je fais partie
de ceux qui étaient favorable l'an
dernier à la taxation des super profits
les super dividendes c'est autre chose
mais mais c'est vrai que l'intérêt
l'intérêt de ce sujet c'est c'est de
mettre dans le débat public la question
de savoir comment on peut mieux répartir
un certain nombre de richesses voilà moi
je crois que ça participe à cette
justice sociale que nous devons à no
compatriotes et donc je suis je suis
toujours ouverte à à ce débat je
m'interroge sur les conséquences en
termes financiers évidemment en terme de
liberté aussi d'entreprendre pour un
certain nombre de sociétés parce que
divid fruitrib le gouvernement n'a pas
entendu cette demande de taxer en tout
cas les super profit voir les super
dividendes qu'est-ce que vous des
demandes même au sein de la majorité
présidentielle oui oui oui c'est c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas été qui n'a
pas été accepté ni par le gouvernement
ni alors par une partie de la majorité
je dirais mais moi ce dont je suis
persuadée que c'est le débat le débat
reviendra voilà le débat reviendra
peut-être sous une autre forme mais
c'est jamais inintéressant bah à
l'occasion certainement du prochain
texte de loi de finan ex dans un an et
vous qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez vous
souhaitez que on en demande plus on
demande plus d'effort au plus aisés dans
cette période
d'inflation pour moi ça ça
n'est je crois que c'est important oui
je crois que c'est important cet effort
de solidarité nationale euh par exemple
sur les super profits je je trouve que
ça n'était pas déraisonnable de
considérer que à un moment donné quand
une entreprise dégageait des bénéfices
sans sans avoir rien fait c'est-à-dire
simplement bénéficier entre guillemets
de la crise de dire qu'elle pouvait
participer à un certain niveau
c'estàdire quand on avait vraiment des
bénéfices exceptionnels pouvaient
participer à cette redistribution au
profit de ceux qui en avaient le plus
besoin comp tenu de la période comp tenu
de difficultés que rencontrit un certain
nombre de familles par exemple pour
financer le bouclier
tarifaire est-ce que euh vous présidez
une partie de ces séances budgétaires
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
est l'ambiance en en séance et surtout
est-ce que vous pensez que l'Assemblée
nationale peut tenir dans ces conditions
entre 493 motion de censure jusqu'en
2027 en tout cas elle a tenu jusqu'ici
elle a tenue jusqu'ici parce que la
configuration de l'Assemblée nationale
nous oblige nous contraint à aller texte
par texte Rechercher des majorités alors
c'est vrai que ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie mais finalement je pense que
c'est une méthode de travail plutôt
saine je crois que c'est important
d'engager le dialogue avec les groupes
d'opposition je pense qu'il faut avoir
cette culture de travail aussi c'est
vrai que les débats sont dynamique moi
qui préside effectivement ces séances
publiques je le je le sens du haut du
perchoir mais en même temps c'est la vie
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est important
que les groupes politiques ils sont 10
alors ils sont nombreux mais c'est
important qu'ils puissent s'exprimer
c'est important que les gens se sent
représentés des débats tendus il y en a
toujours eu en réalité toujours mais
c'est vrai que voilà cette vie à
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que c'est
important que les Français ressentent
merci Naima mchou ce sera le mot de la
fin de cette émission merci à tous de
l'avoir suivi à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine